[Applause]
[Music]
it's week six of the masked singer and
another mass celeb has missed the spot
and flown home hi guys I'm Deidre Behar
and I'm Charlie O'Keeffe yeah the
ladybug may have a red-hot performance
but fans weren't exactly buggin over it
let's fly into the latest elimination
Oh oh my goodness Kelly Osbourne
Osbourne I'm gonna pat myself on the
back here because I have been guessing
Kelly since week one and I was right I
am really really convinced on this one
being Kelly Osbourne the clue package
threw a lot at us we saw them in a TV
studio we saw a wheel at one point I
think there was like nine different
images on the screen kind of throwing me
in a few different directions but she
did say she was born into the limelight
which is a big part of it and there's
very few families who have really stuck
with being in the limelight right and
Kelly Osbourne's family is certainly one
of them take that Sharon Osbourne and
your ham so nice job to you you have
said this since day one borrow a dollar
on all the credit
I think after watching tonight's episode
it was extremely evident that it was
absolutely Kelly Osbourne I noticed
during the clue package when we saw that
deck of cards
it said ace 984 which could be 1984 aka
the year Kelly was born I also really
loved her physical clue the golf cart I
was like what does a golf cart have to
do with maybe Kelly Osbourne well we did
a little digging and in her book there
is no effing secret letters from a
badass she tells a story about ramming a
golf cart into a port-a-potty that
actually caused such a big mess her
parents were charged a $5,000 cleanup
sanction which is insane she's wild she
is an aside from her running golf carts
into things she actually had a makeup
line with her mother Sharon in 2014 for
mac cosmetics we saw her putting on
makeup people putting a makeup on her as
the ladybug so that clue was definitely
thrown in there as well I'm sad to see
Kelly go I was actually really liking
listening to her say I was surprised I
didn't know she had that voice but now
America knows I love it we'll miss you
Kelly listen guys it's time to buckle up
because we still have four more math
stars to review first up the Fox who
shut down the stage with an epic
throwback
[Applause]
all right what do you think I'm going
back to my Gus of Wayne Brady I'm
knocking back Jamie Foxx from last week
and sticking with Wayne Brady I'm right
there with you I'm gonna officially take
back my guest from last week Leslie Odom
jr. I thought there were enough clues to
support that but this is for sure Wayne
Brady it's all pointing towards him now
okay tell me why you think it's Wayne
okay so I was actually looking at the
set list clue we saw a list of songs
first one is everybody say yeah that is
the Hugh Jackman finale song from kinky
boots on Broadway which Wayne starred in
in 2015 to 16 and you saw I did see that
he was incredible heard that amazing
voice and then next to that was sugar
daddy that is actually a song from
Hedwig and the Angry Inch now Wayne
himself didn't star in this but Neil
Patrick Harris did it's a long stretch
here but he was a guest star on How I
Met Your Mother
with Neil Patrick Harris that could tie
that there there's a friendship there's
a friendship there and then cabaret
obviously you think cabaret the Broadway
musical I'm thinking more so the
hundreds of cabarets that Wayne Brady
has done in across the country and
performed in and then finally you and me
this is actually his own song from his
2008 album titled a long time coming
take a look
[Music]
No
[Applause]
I love that you found that piece of
evidence I found another piece of like
vocal evidence so we saw the clue in the
package that said foxhole Hotel and I
thought they were trying to give us
another red herring and steer us towards
thinking it's Jamie Foxx well listen to
this Jamie Foxx used to have a serious
radio station and actually Wayne has
appeared on it and he's actually
freestyled take a listen and just one
more piece of evidence so we can really
hammer it in that it's Wayne Brady he
alluded to the fact that he's had a
30-year career
so being mathematicians that we are over
here uh Wayne is 47 and I went on his
IMDB he actually got his first credit in
1990 on a show called Superboy now I
think Superboy is a really interesting
clue that's a clue in it of itself
totally because there's been so many
superhero references so we've got the
superhero reference plus the 30 year
career how much more evidence do we need
I know I'm locking in Wayne Brady here I
don't need any more clues it's Wayne
Brady and now more power to the flour
baby we are amazed by her take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
those vocals vocals scream Miss Patti
LaBelle yes we're still sticking with
our original guests Miss Patti LaBelle
so so many things to kind of unpack in
her clue package this week she said that
she loves when it's oh so quiet another
thing we're not falling for that is a
Bjork song and I know dr. ken he
certainly thinks this is Bjork but it's
not at all but interestingly Patti
LaBelle has a song called quiet time
take a listen
there's a lady on stage she may not be
ladies but she seems so not only that
song there was another musical piece of
evidence she mentioned a secret garden
well secret garden his name of a song
that Patti put out with Pamela Williams
and Teena Marie what do you think I
support it we're just listing off all of
Patti's photography exactly now I
actually got one of the first Clues we
saw in the package was talent show it
kind of hinted to that well when she was
16 patti labelle entered and won a
talent competition at her high school
which kind of jump-started her career on
top of that we also heard her say
something about the flower having a
scent
well of course being Miss Patti and
being the same famous person that she is
she had a scent Patti LaBelle by Patti
LaBelle through entrepreneur
entrepreneur these fragrances this woman
does all of it and to top it all off I
thought the best one she kind of said at
the end to their boo boo that's
something we've heard Patti say before
an interview so take a listen to that
no no boo boo she's pastor Greeley she's
no man's first lady anymore next she's
not a regular tree she's a cool tree
check this out
[Applause]
I was still kind of thinking Amy Sedaris
at the top of this clue package after
last week after last weekend even this
week there was a little a little bit in
there but your clue discovering and
researching actually hint at someone
else what'd you find
okay well I appreciate you saying that
because all of our our friends on
YouTube really came for me last week no
one thinks this is Lea Michele and
listen I I completely admit I was wrong
on that guess I just wanted it to be
someone who I and like such a
Christmassy sort of fan of like I
listened to Lea Michele's Christmas
album I thought it could be Lacey
Chabert who's in so many Christmas
movies but after the clue package
tonight we do both agree that we think
it's now on a gasteyer who is such an
incredible actress and a performer and
girl can sing and this goodness
definitely been the hardest one to
figure out this one continually seems to
stump us hence why we've had so many
guesses throughout the weeks unlike some
of the other ones where we're like no we
know this one has really given a sort of
like a fun rollercoaster ride so let's
kind of dive into why we now think it's
on a gas tire so in the clew package she
said the new girl at school
well of course my favorite role of Ana's
ever she played Lindsay Lohan's mom in
Mean Girls
you love ladysmith black mambazo but
she's my friend and I made her a promise
there was also a blank play bill and so
that means it's somebody who's obviously
done a lot of work in theater while
Ana's been in nine Broadway place which
is pretty freakin incredible we're
getting a lot of Broadway performers
celebrities who have been featured in
Broadway shows well they're so
comfortable on stage and you can theater
yeah I mean this is a natural-born
performer the the quality of the voice
and the way she moves is just a
spectacular I don't know about you but
the first week I think the judges
mentioned it as well I didn't think this
was a professional singer
I think the first week it was kind of
leaning - what made you need that I just
didn't feel like the vocals were
honestly that insane but these past few
performances they've been spot-on oh my
god she even have goosebumps like
thinking about what a powerful performer
she is and how she really commands the
stage there's a lot of performers who
are like really nervous and really shy
but this the tree did not come to play
and one of the clues that I didn't
exactly get a the start but once I
started looking into her career she said
beamed into another dimension
okay and it was actually featured on a
show called people on earth it was on
TBS in 2016 and it was a sci-fi comedy
about a support group for people who
thought they'd been abducted by aliens
so normal so normal normal yes you are
special whoa what is this
and another one the item clue I think
this was kind of the giveaway for us we
saw a bowl of soup right so initially I
thought what some of the judges thought
like oh is this someone who's done a
soup commercial and Gamble's commercial
but actually Anna got one of her starts
in the industry by being on an iconic
episode of Seinfeld called The Soup Nazi
watch come on Lou get out Nick and I
think my favorite part about that is
that she was credited as a woman just
woman woman before she was on a gas tire
she was a guest star on Seinfeld the
soup has got her a long way
lastly we got a singer who has us all in
the doghouse till we finally guess who
he is take a look at the Rottweiler
[Music]
[Applause]
is this still your favorite performer
yes that performance was insane I feel
like every week you're just like can I
get this and my personal it's got a five
player I want it on my discovery weekly
every week it's so good I mean we're
gonna keep with our Chris Daughtry
series yes even though this clue package
was seriously so hard I want to know if
you thought you know there were any like
particular things that really stood out
to you all that really stood out to me
was again a North Carolina flag and we
know Chris Daughtry is from North
Carolina so more of that the other big
thing was the physical clue so he drew a
picture of triumph the insult comic dog
and it was actually really really good
well turns out Chris Daughtry is
multi-talented the guy can't only sing
he also draws here's what he told comic
book calm I've been an artist since I
was like five years old way before I had
any interest in music at all right after
I got off Idol no.6 I really got back
into comic books and realized how bad I
was and wanted to hone my skills a
little bit
who knew he's doing a great job if you
follow him on Instagram he's got
drawings galore galore and I will say
the crime scene clue not something I
would have pinned with Chris Daughtry
have anything to do well doctor he
actually made his acting debut on the
hundredth episode of CSI in New York and
he has written multiple episodes of NCIS
la oh my gosh no crime music artistry
what does this guy not do I don't know
about I have yeah all that and I think
the the fans are definitely guessing
Daughtry it's been stuck with this since
the start I don't know if there's anyone
else we're still thinking but I'm
sticking with doctor here I'm sticking
with Daughtry do you agree with us let
us know that's not alright we've still
got eight mast singers in the
competition going for that top spot
we'll be back here next week per usual
diving deeper into clue packages and
performances and of course don't forget
to post your comments below and tweet us
who you think the remaining few
celebrities are I'm at Charles E O'Keefe
and am at Deidre Behar we'll see you
next week
[Music]